I live, eat, and breathe sports.
And the new Samsung Smart TV with Smart Interaction, Smart Content...
...is in a league of its own.
Hi, TV.
Smart Hub.
See that?
This TV actually recognizes my voice...
...and pulls up the Samsung Smart Hub,...
...giving me instant access to my favorite apps like ESPN ScoreCenter,...
...so I can keep track of the latest news without missing a second of the action.
It's how you keep track of hoop scores across the country.
Fighting Lemurs won in overtime!
What's a lemur?
Hi, TV!
Smart Hub.
Browser.
It looks like a squirrel.
Intimidating.
Hi, TV!
Smart Hub.
Okay, so the best part about this TV...
...is that it features this incredibly cool voice and gesture control.
It's never been easier to explore a world of content.
Alright, now that you know a little more about the new Samsung Smart TV,...
...I'm gonna check out some highlights.
In the meantime, why don't you tell me your favorite sports highlights by posting in the feed below.
And if you wanna learn more about this amazing TV,...
...be sure to visit Samsung.com/SmartInteraction.
Later.